مرحباً اسمي Olivia Lanes وأهلاً بكم مجدداً في الحوسبة الكمومية في التطبيق العملي. هذه الحلقة الثانية: الدوائر
الكمومية. سنغطي عدة مواضيع في درس اليوم لكن ما أريدكم أن تخرجوا بمعرفته هو الأشياء الثلاثة التالية: أولاً ما هي حواسيب IBM
الكمومية فعلاً حتى تكون لديكم على الأقل صورة تقريبية في ذهنكم لما تفعلونه عندما ترسلون مهمة لأحدها عبر
السحابة. ثانياً ما هو Qiskit وما هي Primitives وكيف يمكننا استخدامها لإنشاء وتنفيذ دوائر كمومية.
سنناقش أيضاً على مستوى عالٍ الأنواع المختلفة من معالجات IBM الكمومية المتاحة وما يميز واحداً عن آخر. وثالثاً
وأخيراً سير العمل النموذجي الذي نتبعه لتشغيل تجارب على نطاق واسع. هذا يشمل اختيار أفضل Primitives
لحالة استخدامكم وتعيين مشكلة على circuit كمومية وتطبيق قمع وتخفيف الأخطاء التي تمكننا
من استخلاص أقصى قوة ممكنة من هذه الآلات. هناك الكثير من المعلومات هنا لكن ابقوا معي
لأننا قريباً سنجمعها كلها في سياق بعض الأمثلة الحقيقية. أولاً لنناقش بإيجاز الـ qubit والعتاد الكمومي
الفعلي. كتجريبية يمكنني أن أعدكم أنه رائع وحقاً يساعد في ربط النقاط
لتصور ما يحدث فعلاً عندما تُرسل المهام لحاسوب كمومي عبر السحابة. المعالجات التي
سنستخدمها مبنية بـ qubit ترانسمون فائقة التوصيل. هكذا يبدو معالج IBM كمومي صغير
هذه المربعات الصغيرة هنا هي الـ qubit نفسها لذا يوجد خمسة إجمالاً على هذه الشريحة. الترانسمون
نفسه هو مكثف ويتكون من لوحين معدنيين موصولين بالتوازي مع محرض غير خطي يُسمى
وصلة Josephson. لكن لرؤية وصلة Josephson عليكم فعلاً التكبير أكثر. إنها مصنوعة من طبقتين
متداخلتين من معدن فائق التوصيل وحيث تتداخل القطعتان وتتلامسان هي الوصلة. وصلة
Josephson هي عنصر يمكن استخدامه لإنشاء ذرة اصطناعية بمستويات طاقة متعددة ونعزل
مستويي الطاقة السفليين كحالة الـ qubit. الخطوط المتعرجة هنا تمثل رنانات الموجات الدقيقة
أي خطوط نقل ثنائية الأبعاد مقترنة بالـ qubit. عندما نبرمج بوابة فهذا يعادل أساساً اختيار
نبضة موجات دقيقة معايرة بدقة عالية والتردد والسعة والشكل والمدة المحددة لهذه النبضات تجعل
الـ qubit يفعل أشياء محددة. تعليمات نبضة الموجات الدقيقة تنتقل من حاسوبكم إلى السحابة
ثم تُقرأ وتُفسر بواسطة إلكترونيات تحكم بدرجة حرارة الغرفة تأخذ تلك التعليمات وتولد
النبضات فيزيائياً. نسميها نبضات موجات دقيقة لأنها جميعها تقع ضمن نطاق تردد الموجات الدقيقة
وهو حوالي 1 جيجاهرتز. بعد أن تنشئ صناديق التحكم بدرجة حرارة الغرفة النبضات تنتقل عبر الكابلات
إلى المبرد التخفيفي وفي النهاية إلى شريحتنا الكمومية. الإشارة تدخل الرنانات عبر
وصلة سلكية على هذه الوسادات ثم تتدفق عبر خط النقل إلى الـ qubit. أعلم أن هذا كله قد
يكون تقنياً بعض الشيء وهذه التفاصيل ليست حاسمة للفهم فيما سيأتي لكن آمل الآن أنكم
جميعاً يمكنكم على الأقل تصور النظام الفيزيائي الذي أنتم على وشك التفاعل معه. فأين توجد هذه الحواسيب الكمومية
فعلاً؟ IBM لديها عشرات الحواسيب الكمومية حول العالم وقد حدّثنا أسطولنا مؤخراً ليحتوي
فقط على معالجات بأكثر من 100 qubit كما ذكرت في الدرس السابق. بعضها موجود في مركز بيانات
IBM Quantum في شمال ولاية New York. تلك الأنظمة منشورة على السحابة لاستخدام الجميع وبعضها
أنظمة مخصصة في الموقع مع جميع الإلكترونيات لتشغيلها والتي تدعم شركاءنا
في شبكة IBM الكمومية. الآن لنتحدث عن Qiskit وهو مجموعة تطوير البرمجيات مفتوحة المصدر من IBM
المصممة للعمل على الحواسيب الكمومية. من الآن سأشير إليها بـ SDK الخاص بـ Qiskit. هناك أيضاً
نظام Qiskit البيئي وهو مجموعة من البرمجيات والدروس والدوال المبنية على أو التي توسع الوظائف الأساسية لـ Qiskit وكذلك
Qiskit Runtime وهي خدمة حوسبة كمومية ونموذج برمجة يسمح للمستخدمين بتصميم وتنفيذ
أعباء عملهم الكمومية بكفاءة باستخدام Primitives في Qiskit. والـ Primitive هو أساساً كتلة بناء صغيرة
يمكنكم استخدامها لتصميم دوائر أكبر أو مهمة. الـ Primitives الاثنتان الأكثر أهمية لنا هما
أخذ العينات والمقدر وسنناقشهما بمزيد من التعمق قريباً. إذا لم تكونوا قد نزّلتم وثبّتتم
SDK الخاص بـ Qiskit بعد فلا وقت أفضل من الحاضر. Qiskit 1.0 أُصدر مؤخراً وهو أكثر أداءً
واستقراراً من أي وقت مضى. لذا لمن بدأتم للتو أتيتم في الوقت المثالي. لمن
هم على دراية بـ Qiskit بالفعل ستحتاجون لتنزيل وإعادة تثبيت الإصدار الأحدث. نوصي باستخدام
pip لتثبيت Qiskit و Qiskit Runtime وتشغيلهما عبر دفتر Jupyter في متصفح ويب من اختياركم. ستحتاجون أيضاً
لتثبيت Jupyter Notebook أو JupyterLab في حال لم تفعلوا ذلك بالفعل. هذه الأدوات كلها مجانية
ويمكنكم تشغيلها على جهازكم المحلي بدون أي تكلفة. تأكدوا من إضافة Qiskit مع خيار
تبعيات التصور ليعمل مع Jupyter ويتيح لكم رسم الأشياء. ستحتاجون أيضاً لإعداد بيئة Python افتراضية وهناك
تعليمات لكيفية فعل ذلك على صفحة تثبيت Qiskit المربوطة هنا. بمجرد أن تصبحوا على دراية بـ Qiskit وتكونوا
مستعدين لتشغيل مهام على حواسيب كمومية حقيقية ستحتاجون للتسجيل في quantum.com وإنشاء رمز
API لـ IBM Quantum وهناك رابط هنا لذلك أيضاً. شرح تفصيلي لكيفية فعل ذلك اتبعوا جميع
التعليمات في صفحة التوثيق كما ذكرت أو يمكنكم مشاهدة فيديو تثبيت البرمجة مع Qiskit هنا
وكلاهما مرفق في الوصف. الآن نحن شبه مستعدين للبدء بالحديث عن الدوائر
الكمومية. بما أن هدف هذه الدورة هو تعليمكم كيفية توسيع مهامكم لتشغيلها بمقياس أكثر من 100
qubit أعتقد أن الطريقة الأكثر بنّاءة للمضي قدماً هي النظر أولاً في سير العمل الشامل الذي سنتبعه. وأسهل طريقة لفهم
سير عمل الحوسبة الكمومية النموذجي هي عبر أنماط Qiskit. أنماط Qiskit هي إطار عمل مفاهيمي يسمح للمستخدمين بتشغيل أعباء
عمل كمومية بتنفيذ خطوات معينة بأدوات نمطية. هذا يسمح بإجراء مهام الحوسبة الكمومية بواسطة
بنية تحتية حوسبة متنوعة وقوية. هذه الخطوات يمكن تنفيذها كخدمة ويمكن أن
تتضمن إدارة الموارد مما يسمح بقابلية تركيب سلسة للقدرات الجديدة مع تطويرها. هنا
الخطوات الرئيسية التي سيتعرف عليها مستخدمو Qiskit ذوو الخبرة على الأرجح. الخطوة الأولى هي التعيين. هذه الخطوة
تُرسّم كيف نأخذ مشكلة عامة نهتم بها ونكتشف كيفية تعيينها على حاسوب كمومي
على شكل circuit. بعد ذلك نحسّن. في هذه الخطوة نستخدم transpiler الخاص بـ Qiskit لتوجيه وترتيب
الـ circuit على عتاد كمومي فيزيائي فعلي. هذا يشمل ترجمة البوابات الكمومية الفردية إلى تسلسلات
العمليات التي تُنفذ على العتاد وكذلك التحسين في ترتيب تلك البوابات. بعد ذلك ننفذ.
Primitives في Qiskit Runtime توفر الواجهة لعتاد IBM الكمومي التي تسمح بتشغيل الـ circuit المنقولة.
هذه الخطوة تشمل أيضاً استخدام تقنيات قمع وتخفيف الأخطاء التي يمكن تجريدها بشكل كبير عن المستخدم. أخيراً نعالج لاحقاً. في
هذه الخطوة تُعالج البيانات من المعالج الكمومي نفسه لتزويد المستخدم بنتائج مفيدة عن المشكلة الأصلية. أساساً هذه الخطوة
تشمل أي تحليل إضافي للبيانات المكتسبة. الآن نحن مستعدون لمناقشة أساس البرامج
الكمومية وهي الدوائر الكمومية. آمل أنكم على دراية بالدوائر الكمومية بالفعل لكن في حال لم تكونوا قد تريدون الاطلاع على الدرس
الثالث الدوائر الكمومية وهو جزء من فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمومية المرفق أدناه. سنقدم
تذكيراً قصيراً هنا فقط. الـ circuit الكمومية هي شبكة من البوابات والقياسات الكمومية مرتبطة
بأسلاك تمثل الـ qubit. الدوائر الكمومية تُقرأ كالنوتة الموسيقية من اليسار إلى اليمين بدءاً من
الزمن صفر الموجود أقصى اليسار. الـ qubit الافتراضية أي التي لم تُعيّن بعد على
qubit فيزيائي على معالج تُرتب تصاعدياً من أعلى لأسفل. بمجرد إعداد الـ circuit يمكننا إضافة
بوابات إليها. بوابات الـ qubit المفرد مثل بوابة Hadamard هنا تؤثر فقط على الـ qubit الموجود على سلكها. بوابات الـ qubit
المتعددة مثل CNOT هذه تؤثر على اثنين أو أكثر من الـ qubit المرتبطة بالبوابة. هنا في هذا المثال حالة الـ qubit واحد تتغير
اعتماداً على حالة الـ qubit صفر. بعد تطبيق جميع البوابات يمكننا إجراء قياسات
تُسجل النتائج على سجلات كلاسيكية. خاصية واحدة مهمة بشكل خاص
للـ circuit هي عمقها. عمق الـ circuit الكمومية هو الحد الأدنى لعدد طبقات البوابات الكمومية المنفذة
بالتوازي المطلوبة لإكمال الحساب المعرف بالـ circuit. للتوضيح البوابات الكمومية يمكن تنفيذها
بالتوازي أو بعبارة أخرى في نفس الوقت بالضبط عندما لا تتشارك أي qubit. لكن إذا أثرت بوابتان أو أكثر
على نفس الـ qubit فلا يمكننا تنفيذها بالتوازي ونُجبر على تنفيذها واحدة تلو الأخرى. لأن البوابات الكمومية تستغرق وقتاً
للتنفيذ فإن عمق الـ circuit يتوافق تقريباً مع مقدار الوقت اللازم للحاسوب الكمومي لتنفيذ
الـ circuit. لذا معرفة عمق الـ circuit مهم لمعرفة ما إذا كان يمكن تشغيلها على جهاز معين أم لا. وسيخبرنا أيضاً إذا كانت
لديها فرصة جيدة لإنتاج نتيجة دقيقة. بعد ذلك لننتقل لاختيار المعالج الكمومي. IBM
أصدرت مؤخراً أسطولاً جديداً بالكامل من المعالجات جميعها بأكثر من 100 qubit ويمكنكم تسجيل الدخول إلى quantum.com لرؤية
المعالجات التي لديكم وصول إليها. المعالجات كلها مسماة بأسماء طيور لأسباب ما والشعارات المختلفة
تمثل أنواعاً مختلفة من المعالجات. مثلاً هذه تمثل معالجات Eagle وهذه الأيقونة هي
Heron. أسماء المعالجات المحددة موجودة أيضاً في الأعلى وكلها مسماة بأسماء مدن لكن هذا
لا يعني بالضرورة أن المعالج موجود فيزيائياً في تلك المدينة. هذه مجرد أسماء. عدد الـ qubit
و EPLG و CLOPS هي أيضاً عوامل مدرجة. سنستعرض كلاً منها.
الـ qubit: هذا واضح جداً. الـ qubit هو ببساطة العدد الإجمالي للـ qubit المتاحة للاستخدام على ذلك المعالج الكمومي
أو QPU. EPLG يعني الأخطاء لكل بوابة طبقية وتقيس متوسط خطأ عملية البوابة في سلسلة طبقية من
100 qubit. أساساً تريدونه أن يكون صغيراً قدر الإمكان. CLOPS يعني عمليات طبقة الـ circuit في الثانية
ويقيس عدد طبقات circuit حجم كمومي وهي circuit افتراضية يمكن لوحدة QPU تنفيذها لكل وحدة زمنية.
كلما زاد الرقم كلما حسبنا أسرع. هذا مكافئ لما تعنيه FLOPS في الحوسبة الكلاسيكية. هذه
المقاييس المختلفة قد تكون أكثر أو أقل أهمية حسب مجال التطبيق المحدد الذي تهتمون به. بعد ذلك لنناقش على مستوى عالٍ
التعيين على الدوائر الكمومية. الخطوة الأولى هي خطوة التعيين التي تجيب أساساً على السؤال: كيف
أترجم مشكلتي إلى circuit كمومية يمكن تشغيلها على عتاد كمومي؟ لا شك في ذلك
التعيين مشكلة صعبة وهو مجال بحث نشط. أحياناً مجرد القدرة على أخذ مشكلة حسابية
والتوصل إلى تسلسل من البوابات الكمومية يساعد في حلها هو الجزء الأصعب. لا توجد طريقة مضمونة
تكفل النجاح لكن هناك إرشادات موصى بها وأمثلة على مشاكل نعرف بالفعل كيفية
تعيينها. الإرشاد الأول هو ترك الحواسيب الكلاسيكية تقوم بأي عمل هي أفضل فيه بنفسها.
المهام السهلة للحواسيب الكلاسيكية على الأرجح لن تستفيد من حاسوب كمومي. الحواسيب الكمومية للمشاكل الصعبة كلاسيكياً.
بالطبع إذا كانت هذه أول مرة تستخدمون فيها Qiskit أو حاسوباً كمومياً فلا تقلقوا بشأن إيجاد مشكلة معقدة حسابياً. قسموها
إلى مشاكل أصغر يمكنكم تعلم معالجتها قبل الذهاب مباشرة لمشروع بمقياس الفائدة العملية. بعد ذلك ترجموا
النتائج لمشكلتكم التي تريدون قياسها أو فهمها إلى مشكلة قيمة متوقعة أو مشكلة
أخذ عينات. لمعظم أنواع المشاكل هذا يتوافق أساساً مع حساب دالة تكلفة. دالة التكلفة هي
دالة خاصة بالمشكلة تعرف هدف المشكلة كشيء يُصغّر أو يُعظّم ويمكن
استخدامها لرؤية مدى جودة أداء حالة تجريبية أو حل بالنسبة لذلك الهدف.
هذا المفهوم يمكن تطبيقه على تطبيقات متنوعة في الكيمياء والتعلم الآلي والمالية والتحسين وغيرها.
كذلك تذكروا أن العتاد الذي ستستخدمونه له طوبولوجيا محددة. بعض الـ qubit غير متصلة
وبعضها متصل وفي النهاية ستحتاجون لتعيين مشكلتكم على circuit تمثل هذا. معالجات IBM الكمومية
تستخدم ما يُسمى طوبولوجيا سداسية ثقيلة والتي تعادل أساساً اتصالات qubit في شبكة سداسية
وسنتعمق في هذا لاحقاً في الدورة. حالياً أهم شيء يجب تذكره هو أن هذه المرحلة تتطلب
ممارسة. تحتاجون لفهم جيد ليس فقط لمشكلتكم بل أيضاً لقدرات العتاد
الكمومي وسنمر بمثال محدد وحالة استخدام لاحقاً لنرى كيف يمكن تحقيق أفضل
توازن. الآن لنناقش كيفية تحسين circuit للعتاد الذي اخترناه. الهدف العام من
خطوة التحسين هو تعيين جميع الـ qubit الافتراضية من الـ circuit على qubit حقيقية فعلية في مكان ما على
طوبولوجيا المعالج. القاعدة الأساسية هي تقليل الأخطاء قدر الإمكان. لفعل هذا نحتاج أولاً
لتوجيه وترتيب الـ circuit بكفاءة. أول شيء يجب تذكره هو أن ليست جميع الـ qubit متصلة كما
قلت بالفعل. بعضها بعيد فعلاً عن بعضها على الشريحة لذا نحتاج لتقليل أو إزالة التفاعلات البعيدة
كلما أمكن. يمكنكم تطبيق تسلسل من بوابات التبديل بين الـ qubit المتجاورة لنقل معلومات
الـ qubit لكن بوابات التبديل مكلفة وعرضة للأخطاء لذا قد تكون هناك طرق أفضل للقيام بذلك. بعد ذلك الترتيب
والتوجيه عمليات تكرارية وتُعيّن qubit افتراضي في الـ circuit على qubit فيزيائي على
العتاد. يمكنكم فعل هذا يدوياً لكن هناك أيضاً أدوات في Qiskit يمكنها تقديم توصيات لترتيب الـ qubit
الفيزيائي بناءً على معدلات الأخطاء التقريبية. بعد ذلك يمكننا دمج تسلسلات بوابات الـ qubit المفرد المؤثرة على نفس الـ qubit
في بوابات مفردة ويمكننا أيضاً أحياناً التخلص من بوابات أو تركيبات بوابات غير ضرورية. مثلاً
بعض تركيبات البوابات يمكن اختصارها لتركيبات أبسط وأحياناً تركيبات البوابات
تعادل مجرد مشغل هوية بسيط فيمكننا إزالتها ببساطة. يمكنكم فعل هذا تلقائياً باستخدام
transpiler الخاص بـ Qiskit أو يدوياً بوابة بوابة إذا كان لديكم سبب وجيه وتريدون مزيداً من
التحكم. بمجرد تحسين ترتيب الـ circuit والتوجيه وعدد البوابات سواء يدوياً أو باستخدام transpiler الخاص بـ Qiskit
نريد عادةً تصور الـ circuit للتأكد من أن توقيت جميع البوابات منطقي. هناك معامل يمكنكم تفعيله في الـ transpiler
لتصور الخط الزمني لـ circuit والتأكد من أن كل شيء مُصطف كما تتوقعون. الآن لنتحدث عن قمع
الأخطاء. قمع الأخطاء يشير إلى تقنيات متنوعة تحول circuit أثناء الترجمة لتقليل الأخطاء.
وهو مختلف عن تخفيف الأخطاء الذي يحدث بعد تشغيل الـ circuit وسنصل إليه قريباً. الشكلان الأكثر شيوعاً
لقمع الأخطاء التي نستفيد منها هما الفصل الديناميكي ولف Pauli. ستكون هناك بعض
التفاصيل التقنية هنا لكن يمكنكم دائماً العودة لهذا لاحقاً. الأول: الفصل الديناميكي يُستخدم
لإلغاء بعض الضوضاء المؤثرة على الـ qubit فعلياً بتطبيق سلسلة من البوابات التي مجتمعة تعادل
عملية الهوية مثل تسلسلات XX والتي تأثيرها الصافي هو إلغاء قنوات الضوضاء المؤثرة تقريبياً
على الـ qubit. لف Pauli هو طريقة لإدراج بوابات عشوائية لتبسيط الضوضاء المتوسطة. العشوائية تساعد
في منع تأثيرات الأخطاء المختلفة من التراكم بسرعة وتجعل الضوضاء أسهل في التوصيف أيضاً.
هذه الطريقة تشكل أيضاً أساس تقنية تخفيف أخطاء وسنناقش ذلك لاحقاً.
مرة أخرى هناك الكثير من المعلومات هنا ولا تقلقوا إذا لم تستوعبوها كلها فوراً. لحسن الحظ الكثير من هذا يمكن فعله تلقائياً باستخدام
transpiler الخاص بـ Qiskit. النقل يمكن أن يكون صعباً لكنه خطوة حاسمة جداً لتحقيق الفائدة على نطاق واسع
بحيث يتطلب الكثير من التجربة والخطأ لإتقانه والحصول على أفضل النتائج. الآن أريد أخذ استراحة
قصيرة لمناقشة transpiler الخاص بـ Qiskit وقدراته أكثر قليلاً. سأفعل هذا على مستوى عالٍ جداً وسندخل في التفاصيل ونرى
بعض الأمثلة لاحقاً. بشكل عام النقل هو عملية إعادة كتابة circuit مدخلة معينة لتطابق
طوبولوجيا جهاز كمومي محدد وتحسين الـ circuit للتنفيذ والمرونة ضد الضوضاء. كما أنه
يعيد كتابة circuit معينة بالبوابات الأساسية لذلك المعالج الكمومي المحدد الذي اخترتم استخدامه. Qiskit لديه أربع
خطوط نقل مدمجة وما لم تكونوا على دراية بتحسين الدوائر الكمومية بالفعل فأنصح بشدة باستخدام أحد تلك
الخطوط المدمجة. بشكل افتراضي يتضمن الـ transpiler هذه الخطوات الست: التهيئة
والترتيب والتوجيه والترجمة والتحسين والجدولة. التهيئة تشير إلى
أي تمرير أولي مطلوب قبل بدء تضمين الـ circuit على الـ backend. هذا يتضمن عادةً
فك لف التعليمات المخصصة وتحويل الـ circuit إلى بوابات أحادية وثنائية الـ qubit فقط. مرحلة الترتيب تطبق
ترتيباً يُعيّن الـ qubit الافتراضية في الـ circuit على الـ qubit الفيزيائية على الـ backend. التوجيه يعمل بعد تطبيق الترتيب
ويحقن بوابات مثل بوابات التبديل في الـ circuit الأصلية لجعلها متوافقة مع اتصالية
الـ backend. المرحلة الرابعة هي الترجمة. في هذه المرحلة تُترجم البوابات في الـ circuit إلى مجموعة
البوابات الأساسية للـ backend المستهدف. التالي هو التحسين. هذه المرحلة تشغل حلقة التحسين
الرئيسية بشكل متكرر حتى يتحقق شرط مثل الوصول لعمق مستهدف معين. لدينا أربعة مستويات تحسين
مختلفة يمكننا الاختيار منها. الأخير هو الجدولة. هذه المرحلة لأي تمريرات جدولة مدركة للعتاد. على مستوى
عالٍ يمكن التفكير في الجدولة كإدراج تأخيرات في الـ circuit لمراعاة أي وقت خمول على الـ qubit
بين تنفيذ التعليمات. كما قلت هناك أربعة مستويات تحسين تتراوح من 0 إلى 3 حيث
مستويات التحسين الأعلى تستغرق وقتاً وجهداً حسابياً أكثر لكن قد تنتهون بـ circuit أفضل.
مستوى التحسين صفر مخصص لتجارب توصيف الأجهزة وبالتالي يُعيّن فقط الـ circuit المدخلة
على قيود الـ backend المستهدف. لا يُجري أي تحسين. مستوى التحسين الثالث
يبذل أكبر جهد لتحسين الـ circuit. لكن بما أن العديد من تقنيات التحسين في
الـ transpiler مبنية على حلول استدلالية فإن بذل جهد حسابي أكثر لا يؤدي دائماً لتحسين
في جودة الـ circuit الناتجة. إذا كان هذا مثيراً لاهتمامكم يرجى الاطلاع على صفحات الـ transpiler في توثيق
Qiskit المرفقة أدناه. الآن نحن مستعدون لمناقشة التنفيذ الفعلي لـ circuit كمومية.
Primitives في Qiskit Runtime توفر واجهة لعتاد IBM الكمومي وتجرد أيضاً قمع
وتخفيف الأخطاء عن المستخدم. Primitive أخذ العينات يُرجع توزيع شبه الاحتمالات أو العدد
الذي يمثل احتمال قياس سلاسل بت معينة من أصفار وآحاد. Primitive المقدر يُرجع القيم
المتوقعة للمرصودات المقابلة لكميات فيزيائية. بمزيد من التفصيل أخذ العينات يشغل الـ circuit
مرات متعددة على جهاز كمومي ويُجري قياسات في كل تشغيل ويبني توزيع
الاحتمالات من استرداد سلاسل البت تلك. كلما زادت التشغيلات أو اللقطات كلما كانت النتائج أدق
لكن هذا يتطلب وقتاً أكثر والموارد الكمومية المطلوبة لتشغيل ذلك. تحديداً يحسب
احتمال الحصول على كل حالة أساس معيارية ممكنة بقياس الحالة المحضرة بالـ circuit. مقدر
Qiskit يستخدم عملية جبرية معقدة لتقدير القيمة المتوقعة على جهاز كمومي حقيقي عن طريق
تفكيك المرصود إلى تركيبة من مرصودات أخرى لها أُسس ذاتية معروفة وتشغيلها.
وتحت غطاء الـ Primitives توجد التقنيات المسماة تخفيف الأخطاء. تخفيف الأخطاء مصطلح شامل لكل هذا
ويشير أساساً للتقنيات التي تسمح لنا بتقليل أخطاء الـ circuit عن طريق نمذجة ضوضاء الجهاز وقت
التنفيذ. عادةً ينتج عن هذا حمل معالجة مسبقة كمومي مرتبط بتدريب النموذج ومعالجة لاحقة
كلاسيكية لتخفيف الأخطاء في النتائج الخام باستخدام نموذج مُولّد. لكن مقابل هذا
الحمل الإضافي نتمكن من الحصول على نتائج أدق بكثير. هناك تقنيات متعددة يمكننا تنفيذها
لتخفيف الأخطاء وسنستعرض ثلاثاً منها بمزيد من التفصيل. انتبهوا لكن أن هذا مجال
بحث نشط لذا من المرجح اختراع تقنيات جديدة والاستمرار في تحسين القديمة.
مستوى المرونة يزيد التكلفة أو بعبارة أخرى الوقت اللازم لتشغيل مهمتكم. قلنا بالفعل أنه عند
مستوى المرونة صفر الـ transpiler لا يفعل شيئاً فعلياً لـ circuit. لكن بدءاً من مستوى المرونة واحد يقدم طريقة تُسمى
إخماد خطأ القراءة الملفوف أو ما نسميه T-Rex اختصاراً. إخماد خطأ القراءة الملفوف يستخدم لف Pauli
لتخفيف الضوضاء وهو شيء تطرقنا إليه بالفعل. إنها تقنية عامة وفعالة جداً
تجعل الضوضاء أقل عشوائية وأسهل في التعامل. بدءاً من مستوى المرونة اثنين
نقدم استقراء الضوضاء الصفرية أو ZNE اختصاراً. هذه تقنية شائعة حققنا معها نجاحاً كبيراً مؤخراً.
الفكرة وراء ZNE قد تكون مفاجئة بعض الشيء: نضيف فعلاً ضوضاء إضافية
فوق ما هو موجود أصلاً لكن ما يفعله هذا هو أنه يسمح لنا بالاستقراء في الاتجاه المعاكس
للتنبؤ بما ستبدو عليه النتائج لو كانت هناك ضوضاء أقل. يمكن فعل هذا بعدة طرق محددة مثلاً
يمكننا تمديد البوابات لجعلها أطول وبالتالي أكثر عرضة للخطأ أو يمكننا تشغيل بوابات إضافية تُنتج
في النهاية عملية هوية فالـ circuit لا تتغير وظيفياً لكننا نأخذ عينات عمداً من ضوضاء
أكثر. لكن عليكم فعل هذا لكل circuit وكل قيمة متوقعة تريدون تتبعها لذا
يمكنكم رؤية كيف يمكن أن يصبح مكلفاً جداً من حيث الوقت المطلوب. نوع محدد من ZNE يُسمى
تضخيم الأخطاء الاحتمالي PEA اختصاراً. بمجرد تعلم نموذج ضوضاء لبوابة يعمل PEA بأخذ عينات
أخطاء من نموذج الضوضاء ذاك وحقنها عمداً في الـ circuit. كما ذكرت الكثير من التقنيات
الجديدة تستمر في التطوير وستُنفذ نأمل مع رؤيتنا للمزيد يدخل حيز التطبيق. هناك شكل أخير واحد من
تخفيف الأخطاء أريد مناقشته يُسمى إلغاء الأخطاء الاحتمالي. بدلاً من أن يكون على مستوى المرونة الثالث
PEC هو قدرة خاصة عليكم تفعيلها يدوياً في Qiskit لأن الموارد الحسابية
المطلوبة لها لا تتوسع جيداً مقارنة بتقنيات تخفيف الأخطاء الأخرى التي ناقشناها.
تبدأون بتعلم الضوضاء المؤثرة على الـ circuit بتشغيل دوائر تعلم أو توصيف ضوضاء
لكل طبقة فريدة من بوابات الـ qubit الثنائية في الـ circuit. هذه النتائج تتيح لكم وصف الضوضاء
بدلالة مشغلات Pauli. بمجرد معرفة حدود الضوضاء هذه يمكنكم تعديل الدوائر بحيث
تحتوي فعلياً على مشغلات Pauli معاكسة مدمجة لإلغاء قنوات الضوضاء هذه. من بعض النواحي هذه العملية
مشابهة لسماعات إلغاء الضوضاء. لكن طريقة إلغاء الضوضاء هذه مكلفة جداً بوقت تشغيل
ينمو أسياً وبسرعة في عدد البوابات لذا قد لا تكون الخيار الأفضل لـ circuit كبيرة جداً.
وصلنا الآن للمرحلة الأخيرة: المعالجة اللاحقة. في النهاية إذا قمتم بعمل جيد واستخدمتم تقنيات تخفيف أخطاء
مناسبة قد ترون إجابتكم النهائية تنتقل كما في هذا الشكل هنا. التوزيع غير المخفف
الموضح بالبنفسجي بعيد جداً عن القيمة المتوقعة الحقيقية الموضحة هنا بهذا الخط. لكن بمجرد تطبيق تخفيف
الأخطاء نحصل على توزيع مخفف موضح هنا بالأزرق وقمته أقرب بكثير من القيمة الحقيقية.
كل هذا يأتي بتكلفة وهنا يمكننا رؤية أن التباين أو عرض التوزيع يزداد وهو
ليس ما تريدونه عموماً. لكن كل شيء له ثمن. لحسن الحظ يمكننا تعويض هذا بتشغيل لقطات
أكثر مما يجعل التوزيع ينكمش إلى مستوى عدم يقين مقبول. هذا تقريباً كل ما في هذا
الدرس. في المرة القادمة سنأخذ كل هذه الخطوات ونجمعها ونعمل على مجال ومثال
لتطبيق فعلي مهم. هناك بعض الأشياء التي أنصح بها حتى ذلك الحين. إذا لم تفعلوا بعد تأكدوا
من تنزيل وإعداد Qiskit 1.0. يمكنكم أيضاً الاطلاع على الدرس المرافق لهذا الفصل و
الحلقة السابقة في منصة IBM Quantum للتعلم. وأخيراً إذا كنتم مهتمين بالتعمق أكثر و
تعلم المزيد عن تقنيات تخفيف الأخطاء اطلعوا على أحد المصادر العديدة التي ربطتها أدناه. حتى ذلك الحين سنراكم في المرة القادمة
[موسيقى]